[Music]
welcome everybody to this afternoon to
cloud billing we're gonna be talking a
little bit about best practices for
financial governance before we get
started this is a panel it's open Q&A
and so we'll be using Dory as you can
see the instructions they hear and how
to ask questions through the Dory so
please feel free to fire away and we'll
try to get your questions answered as we
go through I'm gonna start with
introduce myself my name is Matt Leonard
I'm the product manager in the cloud
billing team with Google cloud I'm gonna
turn it over to our panelists here so
they can introduce themselves and tell
you a little about what they manage on
GCP hi i'm lucas carlson on the cloud
architect at the Broad Institute of MIT
and Harvard we're a genomics Research
Center in Cambridge Massachusetts and we
do a lot of government-funded research
on Google cloud we use an enormous
amount of Google Cloud storage in the
tens of petabytes and we have a very
interesting model where we charge back
internally to our grants so we have
literally hundreds of billing accounts
within the organization which makes it
very interesting hi my name is Jiang
Joshi I'm a specialist leader as part of
Deloitte's cloud engineering bat group I
work with many of our customers on their
cloud transformation journey and
focusing mostly on cost management
governance and automation everybody I'm
Chris Hoover I work at Etsy I look after
the team of business program managers
finance legal PR those sorts of things
we're about one year into a two year
migration to Google cloud soaring lots
of things so far we've moved our web
platform api's mobile apps but still in
progress with search machine learning
data science those things and still
learning about those things my name is
Dale Hopkins and I'm the CTO of vendetta
technologies we're a software company up
in Saskatoon Saskatchewan that's middle
of Canada and
what we do is we basically help
professionals that sell services to
small business augment those services
with software and so we've got about a
hundred and fifteen thousand small
businesses that use our professionals to
purchase software and we use pretty much
all of GCP except for the genomics API
hasn't come in handy yet excellent
alright well thanks folks
we'll dive straight into a question
Lucas what would you say is the hottest
thing that you have to manage in terms
of managing your DCP cost well as I
mentioned we have a large number of
different billing accounts so when we
get our bill each month we have to sort
of split it up and charge back to like
300 different internal cost objects
which each represent a different
government grant and that whole process
can be pretty tedious for us we have the
problem where grants rollover I'm given
grant might last for a year or three and
then it'll stop and in order to continue
doing work you have to have another
funding source to do it so there's a lot
of moving projects between different
billing accounts and tracking all that
stuff is a big pain and I would say on
top of all that the biggest thing is
trying to control costs to make sure
that users don't spend more than they
intend for us that's a bigger deal than
your average organization because if the
grant you have only provides let's say
10 grand of compute service resources
and you spend more than that the grant
is not gonna pay for it so we just have
to like pay for it out of other funds
and that's really frustrating when you
can't do work you plan to do because
somebody made a little mistake in their
in their cloud account absolutely Chris
would you like to take it from a
different perspective from an C yeah I'm
sorry
hello trouble hearing the question could
you repeat it please sure what's the
hottest thing about managing your GCB
cost yet for us I think it's just kind
of a change in mindset we've come from a
colocation facility on bare metal
resources and consumption of them work
way differently there
the interaction between us and our
finance teams is a little bit different
I think there's a lot to be learned in
terms of how you clarify assumptions and
levels of precision for how we forecast
together how we develop the tooling
together to make sure that we're
anticipating cost with seasonality those
sorts of things so for us it's it's kind
of learning these new muscle memories
and our processes between different
organizations to make them run more
smoothly only that about covers it
sushi shank from your perspective with
managing customers and partners and
helping with the migration to the cloud
like where do you see the opportunity
for them to to add better controls in
their environment absolutely I think
first thing is no-brainer that everybody
should enable their billing export in
bigquery and you should do that on day
one that definitely is one of the
learnings and the opportunity that
everybody should be taking up second
thing is there is enormous amount of
data and information there so the more
you know your team get familiar with the
data and analyzes the data the more
insights you can draw from from your
billing export but I think one of the
hardest challenges that organizations
face is billing is just one piece of
their entire IT organization - how to
overlay their our structure onto GCP
billing export that's that's the
important piece because as Lucas just
mentioned how will you apportion or
attribute some of the costs to different
teams that's that's the hardest thing to
do and you can do it using for example
Labor's and in that case you have to
define the strategy up beforehand and
not just for today and not just for near
future but even for six months one year
down the line because it's really hard
to change the label strategy once you
decide it and go in into that so so some
of those lessons and the opportunities
in terms of deciding that early I would
conclude with one point on that one is
not every organization recognizes the
importance of cost management early on
so there are so many things they worry
about the foundation automation this
tool that tool it's really important to
understand the importance of cost
management and think about it very early
in your
Jemmy great i mean that's a good point
though as you think about you cost
management how you organize you costs
like dale house ven duster approached
organizing they cost within the cloud so
one of the things that we have is we may
take a little bit different approach but
one of the things we like to do is
basically monitor and alert on on
billing as opposed to actually setting
hard limits and things for us making
sure that those the teams actually have
a lot more say in add more understanding
of their actual costs is a really
important part to getting developers to
actually understand the cost
implications of the changes they're
making so i mean really for us it's a
big part of the change is actually
providing that data and i think in a lot
of organizations the the team's actually
writing the code don't understand what
it costs to operate that code that they
shipped and so for us it's actually a
really useful input to them in terms of
determining when to refactor and when to
put more effort into the code is i mean
cost is a really great to metric to help
you with that
yeah it's a great point actually and so
like i'm gonna stay with you for a
second i'm so what keeps you up at night
when you think about that yeah i guess
for me the stuff that keeps you up at
night on cloud is like the the opposite
stuff when you have an on-prem workload
your on-prem workload i think is you're
concerned that there's gonna be a huge
surge in load and you're not gonna be
able to serve your customers the concern
we have is is that you're gonna have a
huge certain surgeon load you're gonna
serve all your customers just fine
you're just not gonna have any money at
the end and so that's the thing with
especially with some of the i mean it's
maybe the double-edged sword of
something like an app engine or pub/sub
or one of these services that basically
scales to infinity is that's awesome but
as long as that's what you wanted
excellent well I see Lukas chuckling
away here and I'm gonna I'm gonna put
this one back on him as well because
last year Lukas and I talked about how
do you build bit of financial
governments controls for your
environment and and Lucas looked about
it for an hour which was great because
it meant nobody had to listen to me so
Lucas so first I'll say that the what
keeps us awake at night is the idea that
someone might have spent a hundred
thousand dollars in the cloud while we
were sleeping and we had one incident on
a on another public cloud where
one of our users either intentionally or
unintentionally spent 100 grand that
they did not have and as I alluded to
that man we just had to pay as a vendor
from another bucket of money that was
not intended for that purpose so that
incident that one incident that happened
several years ago entirely changed how
everyone at the broad thought about the
cloud and building and created a lot of
fear and uncertainty about what we might
do eventually in the cloud and so for us
it's been really important to be able to
automate all of these tasks and the idea
of being able to get notifications in
email from like 300 billing accounts and
process all those notifications and
actually do something appropriate to
respond to them is really challenging so
for us automating that has been key and
last year Matt's team released a feature
which I would say is the second most
important thing you should enable and
your billing account after you get
started which is to have a budget or
many budgets that publish their
notifications to pub/sub when you do
that you can build something like a
cloud function that will receive those
notifications and take potentially
appropriate action on them which means
that I don't have to read every email
that comes from all these billing
accounts and decide what should be done
I can write a cloud function that can do
that
so with 300 or so billing accounts we
get like a thousand notifications an
hour from the billing accounts and each
time that notification kicks off it
kicks off a cloud function which updates
a database so that we have like a single
screen where we can see the status of
all 300 billing accounts at once instead
of having to click through to 300
billing account consoles which is not
something I would ever do and then in
addition we added some logic where we
could put some hard thresholds in place
that we don't want to ever pass and if
one of these budgets passes that
threshold we can automatically take an
action and so the examples that we
showed in our talk last year
was sort of three levels of response one
being notify someone maybe in slack or
or pager duty or something like that
another sort of bigger hammer is to
identify all the VMS that are currently
running in that billing account and stop
them this for us is sort of a nice
medium where we don't lose any data but
we do basically stop a majority of the
spend so if we did have this huge influx
of spend it allows us to really shut
that down fairly quickly and then if you
hit another threshold that makes you
very uncomfortable you can do something
like just turn the billing off on the
projects and they all stopped working
but you do not spend more money so for
the engineering folks we don't really
like that but for the folks in
procurement and in sponsored research
who are managing the grants they
absolutely love that they want to know
for sure that if you were allowed to
spend ten thousand dollars and you hit
ten thousand dollars that you have not
spent a single dollar more than that and
so implementing that has certainly
helped us manage that process so it's a
great segue so Shashank you work with a
lot of customers advise them on how to
set up and organize themselves on GCP
like what kind of like best practices do
you recommend sure I touched upon that
the first thing is that understanding
the importance of cost management
solution in place right and thinking
about it beforehand not as afterthought
so while you're building your platform
or foundation at the same time or even
before that you should be thinking about
your billing solution billing analysis
solution that's the first thing I would
say because not many organization think
think like that the second best practice
we say is of course use the billing
export the other features are really
good in terms of billing reports and
quotas and alerts those are really good
but if you need more insights you need
to use billing export bigquery and
analyze that yourself of course you can
start smaller the other best practice we
say is it's like no-brainer in terms of
don't do all the requirement analysis
beforehand right I want to build this
many dashboards don't start like that
start with like initial dashboards start
tre di-gel fashion when you start
creating dashboards and reports and show
it to stakeholders more and more
stakeholders will buy into your your
initiative and they'll give you more
suggestions and you improve on that and
that's how we help one off a retailer
retail customers with that for example
we started creating new dashboard every
two weeks and it can be a minor
improvement into on the earlier
dashboard but that really helped get
excitement among the people the
consumers of the dashboards and that
really I'd have no right to that option
into that and the importance of that and
I would say final best practice we in
terms of transparency and visibility
what we say is every cloud
transformation should start with some
kind of a business plan and if you don't
have that if you don't start with that
now it's the time to do it because you
need to have what milestones any
initiatives you need to break down all
of that into the minor level details and
then have a solution which can show you
hey your budget for this application was
this much for this up this month and
where are you visibly that because what
we have seen is overall in one example
so at a 1/4 mile stone overall the
organization was under the budget but
they spend much more on initiative one
versus initiative to so even though
overall system looks good but you may be
overspending on something and less
spending on something else so it's very
important to go to granular level to do
a business case go to granular level and
I would say the best case scenario is
what we have seen is they're gone all
the way to individual applications and
individual environments in that
applications so you should know what I'm
supposed to spend on this application on
dev environment in this month it's a
great point actually like so as you
start to think about how you're
organizing your costs and driving that
budget down to that granular level you
start to introduce a bit of a planning
problem Chris oh no it's he you guys
spend a bit of time thinking about this
do you want to talk a little bit about
how it's he thinks about budgeting and
planning for the business sure
absolutely
it looks different for different
Cadence's different frequencies as you'd
imagine with
finance cycles so annually we you know
kick off in about q4 so to think about
all of the roadmap items for our
architecture all the things that
engineering wants to get done and look
at the consumption that comes with those
and then as we march on throughout the
year and the typical agile fashion we
innovate we adapt and take a few curves
in the road and I think the key there is
transparency early notification of your
finance team this will definitely help
them and build confidence and trust in
your relationship with them over time
it'll also even implicitly strengthen
the mutual understanding of the error
margins in those forecasts as you go
further and further on you go to feel
for how each other treats the numbers
and what level of precision were able to
get to at each point and our maturity in
the cloud for us particularly because
we're mid migration the types of things
were working on evolves quickly over
time and so the type of system or tool
that we're using and the team that are
using those that that uses those things
is a very different use case in call
them to solve depending on where it is
in the engineering organization so how
we manage costs and search is very
different from how we measure or in
manage costs for a web platform and so
educating finance on how these problems
need to be solved independently and
uniquely is also a big part of the
process since great points it's so Dale
modesties got a pretty mature offering
now on top of Google cloud and and you
know last year you talked a little bit
about how you drive accountability and
visibility to teams you want to talk a
little bit about some of what you've
learned from how you drive visibility
down to your engineering themes one of
the things we found really useful is the
data export and it particularly helps us
because you don't have to assign
building level permissions to the teams
to have these sort of things but you can
provide them the data scope down to what
they're interested in and so for us it's
I mean just like so many other things in
your organization as soon as you make it
visible
all of a sudden improvements start to
happen and so for us just a big part of
that culture was it's like hey guys
here's your data
and all of a sudden that starts to
actually impact behavior you don't even
have to tell people that what what a
good number or a bad number is if you
just show them a number and explain how
that relates and that they affect that
that made a really big difference for us
in terms of cost and then one of the
other things we found that was helpful
was actually doing like a layer of this
week's costs versus last week's costs
because you're gonna find that like it's
pretty hard to compare to today to
yesterday because for us specifically we
got a lot of small businesses if today's
Saturday and yesterday was Friday it's
not a good comparison because it just
turns out that people tend to do
different things on different days like
that and especially like weekly and
monthly overlays helped the teams so
exact not just presenting them here's a
number but here's a chart over time and
you know if it's up or down a little bit
you know that's okay but if it's way off
it kind of gives teams the idea that
they should look at something great and
this idea of seasonality from day to day
or month to month this is obviously
something that adds he deals with you
know with a queue full Pig how does this
you think about like seasonal
fluctuations we've only got one partial
season under our belts but I'll speak
from that I think we've learned a lot
just in that short period we found it
really helpful to look back at
historical periods even in the data
center and see how seasonality has
impacted our our consumption and I I
would totally agree that the micro
aspect of that the day to day the
weekdays is a big part and you want to
look at how that compounds with larger
macro seasonality from annual holidays
to months of the year and everything in
between
another great conversation to have with
your finance teams is around what they
forecast for the next season and melding
that with your consumption estimates and
therefore your cost estimates that's a
very healthy and helpful conversation to
have with finance to marry the
consumption side and the forecasted
seasonality side and have that in be
informed by what you've seen in previous
season ality at all of those levels of
granularity I'll also say that that also
varies by system or product so
the the economies of scale will
definitely vary based on which GCP
products you're using in which type of
your infrastructure you're using so as
an example with visits to our website
they may double but our consumption of
compute will far less than double which
is good news but we want to be able to
forecast with that good news in advance
great I'm gonna I'm gonna pass it over
to Lucas for a second no Lucas you you
managed with something like six thousand
projects three hundred billing accounts
that's a Philly distributed architecture
and you've got obviously some some
important stakeholders in your planning
process from your accounting and Finance
folks down to your research is like how
do you manage across a distributed group
like that in order to get a plan so you
can build these budgets first I just
want to correct the number that you
mentioned there I think we're at twenty
five thousand projects like that
last year it was ten thousand so there's
been a lot of growth since then so we
have a pretty tight onboarding process
for cloud we use the same process for
all of the public clouds that we support
currently as I mentioned we have most of
our work is funded by government grants
and so internally each of those grants
has a seven digit number that we use as
a cost identifier we call it a cost
object and so that's what people use to
buy things whether they're cloud
services or you know supplies or
whatever they need for their science so
users who have funding and want to use
the cloud have to basically submit a
request through a process with
procurement or they say hey like I have
this funding and I want to use it on the
cloud and if we know based on the number
that it's like an administrative funding
source like like my IT budget is an
admin budget it's not funded by a grant
then it mostly just gets approved the
person who's making the request is the
authority on that cost object and they
can decide how much to spend but if it's
funded by a government grant
than the people who manage the sponsor
research funding I have to be involved
they have to check the grant and make
sure that it has enough funding to
support what the group is intending to
do and then they also have to check the
grant and make sure it actually allows
you to spend money on the cloud and so
all of that has to happen before we even
give them access and then once
everything is approved we basically
create a new billing account for that
particular cost object and give the user
billing account administrator and now
you know they own that billing account
and they're responsible for whatever
happens in it they can delegate
permissions to people within their team
to create projects if they wish or if
they don't have that level of trust with
the people on their team they may choose
to create the projects themselves and
give the teammates access another common
model is users in our company are
allowed to create projects all they want
they're just not allowed to add billing
unless they're a billing account
administrator so people on your team can
create projects and then they can give
you a sufficient level of access to
their project that you can enable
billing on it for them and we have
literally all of these different models
in place at the proed and in addition
you know we have some situations where
projects that we own that are in our
organization are being funded by someone
else's billing account and we have
situations where projects that are owned
by an external organization are being
funded by one of our billing accounts so
basically every scenario you could
imagine we have currently but that
process is what we use whether people
are trying to get on board with Google
or any of the other public clouds
excellent all right Hank you advise a
lot of customers how do you how do you
start like estimating costs for a new
project like ballpark figures like what
does that look like
so to say that I mean sir customer comes
to you and say hey we'd like to move a
work load into Google Cloud and we're
planning to build something completely
new from scratch how do you even go
about ballparking that that budget
estimate yeah that's what tools I guess
are available t to do that right that's
a really good point and the best
practice we follow is during the
migration analysis we do the billing
view of
as well so you have to do the billing
review very early in your in your design
cycle so that's a really good point if
you're not doing that you should be part
of your governance when you planning for
migration application you should see how
the cost of that would be having said
that what we have done to estimate the
cost was looking at the trends looking
at the usage and the customer we had we
actually created no separate calculators
in terms of unit price for example if
you're using compute instances and at a
large scale you would have certain
amount of comity and use discount
sustained use discounts and some of the
other discounts and some percentage of
on-demand rising so what does your unit
price turns out to be for a compute
which is vastly different from what you
see on the website so for all the
services that you're consuming you
should have some kind of a unit price
for your organization worked out that's
not hundred percent accurate but that's
close there and use those unit prices to
estimate your ballpark figure for your
consumption all right so if it's so it's
let's say a simple treat your
application you can say it's how many
compute instances how much data how much
egress so you know how the unit price
for each of the service and you can
estimate the price for that application
but yeah and I think in the interesting
anecdote that me and my discuss before
was the unit price is not constant all
the time right so coming back to the
seasonality questions I was working with
one of the retailers and when you see
this seasonal Black Friday or
Thanksgiving kind of weekend the spike
is much higher and your community uses
disk commitments are for a year or three
years you cannot make a commitment for
one month so how do you manage that and
during that peak cycle your on-demand
usage is going to go up significantly
right so in your in your makeup of
compute instances the ratio of on demand
is gonna increase and that's gonna that
comes at a higher price so your unit
price during the peak is higher than
your regular unit price so when you
estimate for let's say a peak size peak
season you not just have to know
estimate for the additional capacity
that you want but that capacity is maybe
coming at a higher price
so using that seasonal variation also
the unit pricing that's a key to
estimating the price excellent so
there's been a number of questions from
the audience I'm just gonna try and
collate them together in a single one
what tools are you using in order to
organize and then view and then
internally charge back those costs I'm
gonna ask you Chris as a big like
corporation that obviously has many
departments running infrastructure one
to DCP like what are using to manage
this sure right now we're using the
native cloud console it's grown a good
bit in the last year or so we're seeing
some new functionality come out I know
that building product management team at
Google is hard at work and rolling out
new features like getting visibility
into different types of discounts within
the bill so we're anxiously awaiting
more development there that's kind of a
factor in how we're developing our own
use of tools so let me run through the
list of the rest of the things that
we're currently using bigquery data
studio and looker as well for current
dashboards also in the agile fashion of
rolling those out incrementally to kind
of suit the need and show people and let
that that data drive action naturally we
have kind of a two-pronged need here not
just for billing but also for
sustainability goals were very
interested not just in cost efficiency
but also in the efficiencies of the
resources we use the energy that we pull
from the environment and measuring that
so we have double motivation at Etsy to
really get the tooling right and in the
this early stage of our tooling roadmap
were kind of merging and sinking the
paces of that internal tool development
the use of the already provided tools
and understanding kind of where Google
is developing its own functionality for
future features to get an idea of what
this looks like in the steady state for
us I think there's still a good bit more
ahead for us and I'll pass it on to Dale
as well like Dale you've put some pretty
cool stuff using data studio how do you
share those costs around within your
organization data studio any of you in
the audience here with a show of hands
use data studio current
in your organization because it's not
nearly as many as I might have thought
data steal is actually really great in
it allows you to build these dashboards
and so one of the things we've done is
we've actually put together data studio
dashboards and they share kind of like
Google Docs not quite as good but sort
of similar idea and you can actually put
these up on on monitors just in the hall
and so you can actually like in a team's
room have their costs right there and so
they're literally confronted by a chart
of their costs when they walk in the
door so I mean it's a simple tool and it
queries pretty much anything on a
bigquery or any other Google source and
it's it's really quite easy so I'd
encourage you to give it a shot because
it's really not as intimidating and it
makes graphs that are beautiful and I
don't make beautiful graphs so that's
kind of exciting I mean the other tool
that I think is everybody's favorite
that nobody likes to admit they use as
sheets which is awesome too because you
can just dump a raw data in there and
that's something to play with and figure
out before but those are the two tools
that we use one of them is much prettier
than the other for any of you that might
be feeling intimidated about data's few
I'm just a product manager so I was like
I don't know about this data studio
after watching Dale build these amazing
dashboards in about seven minutes on
stage at next last year I was like I'm
an expert this thing is super easy so
definitely encourage any of you to take
a look at it I'm gonna take another one
how much time do you spend Lukas on
managing billing data across your multi
cloud deployments I'm not gonna pick on
GCP here I'm gonna make it multi cloud
because way more than I ever expected
I'm like a tech guy I like to build big
scaling systems in the cloud and it
turns out that I'm like one of the
world's experts on Google billing now
which is not ever something I expected
to have happen so it's quite a bit of
time there's I think you guys have
certainly made it easier over the last
year or two with all the new features
like we've been a GCP customer for a
long time so before the bigquery feature
existed we were manually importing our
CSV s every day into bigquery so that we
had some visibility into the data and
then when you guys release that feature
we didn't have to build that ETL process
anymore we just turn on the switch
before we had access to data studio we
were already a tableau shop so we put a
lot of effort into building some really
advanced tableau reports that do some
very broad specific things like when you
have grant funding and then you use that
grant funding to pay for a cloud service
there's like an overhead tax that gets
applied to that as part of your
organization and so we need to let our
users see what the full loaded cost of
the cloud is going to be not what the
actual bill from Google is going to be
because it's not the same so we have all
those tools built into tableau and then
when data studio came out we have built
a bunch of visualizations and data
studio many of those have actually been
replaced by the features that you guys
have built into the console so I think
now the thing I use the most by far is
the the reports in the console
absolutely and these other tools
sometimes we actually have to take new
features that you guys have brought like
the recent release of the invoice month
and we were now introducing those
features into the data studio and to the
tableau tools that we use as well but
between me and Stewart and procurement I
always spend many many hours a month
dealing with this I mean just the time
that he's funds taking the bill and
charging back to 300 different internal
cost objects 30 or 40 of which will have
expired since the last month so for each
of those he has to go figure out what
the new funding source is and it's like
such a huge burden so we're constantly
working on ways to automate that I'm
building App Engine apps that he uses to
manage the accounts and giving him more
reports and data studio and so forth
great I mean Chris you have a similar
type of environment sorry Shashank I'm
gonna come back to in a minute um you
have a similar type of environment like
how much time is your your organization
spending and and dedicated resources
still organizing and charging back cost
you we have one billing account which
makes it a little bit simpler in
comparison but it is nevertheless
complex we've been very thankful and
standing by the decision to hire a
dedicated resource to manage this full
time
we have a program manager you might find
an analyst to be helpful in spending
full time focus and understanding and
forecasting sort of as a liaison to all
of your engineering teams by product
that they're using and by roadmap type
what they're doing in Google Cloud I
think you'll quickly find that type of
person's time is consumed on very
meaningful things at Etsy that person
Danny he might be here he floats between
finance and accounting and engineering
and speaks very knowledgeably about all
these things along with Google and
there's a kind of a single library of
information that really helps us connect
these things so if you haven't already
or if you're in the early start stages
of starting on the cloud I think as part
of resource planning the people planning
in an analyst or a program manager do
these things proactively is a really
smart call Thanks we see that quite a
bit that customers have somebody who's
dedicated and committed to like what
does what does that cost management
story look like in the cloud I mean sue
Shashank we get a lot of questions from
the audience today about like how do we
organize the cost obviously like Google
has like folders they have projects
these are all visible in the billing
data but one of the things we haven't
really talked about is labels and label
strategy like how how do customers
approach a labeling strategy for their
environment absolutely I think this is I
think the most important part for larger
organizations because GCP exists into a
larger IT ecosystem for big
organizations right so there are lines
of businesses there are vice-president
department heads and application owners
so there is like a big organization
structure outside of GCP so how will you
impose that because nobody wants to see
overall GC because they would want to
see what is my team's cost or what if it
is a vice-president if you want to see
what are all the applications under his
line of business and what how they are
doing visa we the budget that they have
so it's very important how do you do
that and there are two ways to do that
as Matt mentioned one way is recently
announced ending
relatively recently was you can align
your organizers you structure with the
GCP resource organization and by that I
mean your folder structure so we can
have a folder structure dedicated to
vice-president and everything under
related to him is under that and that
data flows into your billing export with
project ancestry so you can use that
field to identify with this project
belongs to this VP right so this is very
simple to start with but you may get any
challenges because if there are projects
shared by two VPS or there is a project
with not assigned to anyone me PR
project moves from one folder to another
there are complications related to that
the other option is and of course this
is at the project level right so but if
you want to go beyond the project if you
are running let's say different
applications within one project how
would you distribute that or different
environments so the best way of doing
that is using labels and labels strategy
as I said you cannot change it often you
have to decide it very early on and not
just for today as I said before you have
to do it for three months or six months
down the line as well because really
hard to change labels now when you are
already in process and I would say some
examples of that using for example it
can be vice president or a department
lob it can be by application it can be
by environment and and I've seen uses
where even the operations team used the
labels for example for patching cycle
and all of that so it's not only billing
related but it's really significant in
terms of billing and all of these label
data flows into into your TCP export or
billing expert in bigquery and again
there are two labels there is there are
project level there are resource levels
so you can even drill down further it's
the opportunities are immense but it's
very complex as well because initially
we struggle I remember two years ago
when labels came in we started try to
use it for in the very beginning it's a
nested field in bigquery and when we try
to sum up everything and all our costs
went up like you know pi times and
everybody was short then we realized so
it it's I I would say really important
that your team is familiar with the
export schema and the number of services
that are launched
so frequently by google cloud the schema
is changing all the time
for example this folder project ancestry
feature was not there last year I
believe right correct so a lot of new
features are coming in to export so it's
it's very important that your team is
familiar and I hope to really change the
schema
yeah thanks there's lots props there for
all the features that we're launching we
are trying to improve things um for
those of you didn't catch it earlier
target did a presentation earlier today
where they talked about their label
strategy and some of the mistakes that
they made not ensuring that they had
consistent label strategy across their
organization early on and then in terms
of governance so if you didn't see that
will be available on YouTube after next
but they talk about how they use for
city in order to govern their
environment I'm sure that their
resources are labeled consistently
across their environment so it's great
so yeah I think one point is well on
this one so where we decided the label
strategy we also had a label labeling
compliance dashboard the dashboard on
how compliant every project is on labels
so if you're missing a label we'll show
you so that as a like you miss the
compliance yeah yep and so we're working
on some tools to help with that but
definitely check out the target sessions
very useful now that the top out voted
question here from the the Dory is
actually how do I reduce my DCP costs
I'd like to take that one first
excellent there's there's lots of
different ways to reduce your costs I
guess this kind of depends on your
particular story in your application I
think so some of the ways that we've
done things is like we started on GCP a
long time ago and some of the cost model
on or on Python to 7 app engine
migrating to a more modern stack can
often change the efficiency use such as
memory and CPU and also the cost model
on some of the gke resources being lower
than those of App Engine standard that's
one way that for us that's our primary
cost reduction model is actually moving
things from App Engine standard into a
more modern runtime I mean app engine
standard has modern runtimes but not the
one that we use one of the other ways is
obviously sitting down look at your GCP
bill and if you are a continuous user
and at the end of it you see a sustained
use discount I mean that's an
opportunity right there to do a
committed discount if that's
that you actually think so I mean
obviously don't do that if you have a
ton of seasonal fluctuation but that's
something that we've also done to save
cost those are the big ones for us well
let everybody take this one Chris
take it away preamp tools might be
another one in a long very similar lines
depending on the workloads so you'd use
would be on one end the spectrum
principles would be on the other but
both they're really high cost savings
off of the list it really depends on
what products you're using I mean if
you're heavy storage users you should
wait near line versus cold line all the
other storage options with what you
actually need
I think auto scaling is also a great
thing to look into across the board some
things are a little bit more complex and
you might want to form like a short-term
squad so to speak of cross-functional
team members from different engineering
teams to look into what could non
disruptively
create some efficiencies there's you
know a little bit of research that could
go a long way potentially and finding
things that you could just use in a
slightly different way but still get the
same benefits from that consumption and
we recommend to approach this in
multiple ways one part of governance is
bi-weekly or weekly we have cost
optimization kind of reports dashboards
and the way we look at that is everybody
looks at the top five cost drivers so if
compute engine was higher for you than
your estimation you drill down so that's
where the dashboard come in so if
compute was high why it was higher so in
many cases we realized licensing cost
was higher so is there a way you can
optimize that using your bring your own
licensing and there's sometimes your
storage costs were higher for discs so
you'll that's where another good feature
comes in you have to marry your billing
data with the platform data so in one
case we had a lot of custom GCP Python
scripts just going around and finding
how many orphan discs that you have the
discs which are not connected to any
server and nobody knows that they exist
so that is that costs gets at added to
your thing so you have to marry your
billing export with the platform data so
you get platform data
to that and finally I would say you have
to make the billing review as part of
your design process so you ought to push
the billing related thing very early
into your design cycle I would say 99%
of the times it's the afterthought they
launch the application migrate the
application they do that years and all
of that but then the month later they
see the cost is gone higher so best
practice is to really do the review much
earlier on do the optimization using
auto scaling or any other features of
optimization early on before you launch
the application on the cloud so let's
see I would say Dale hit on probably the
the best thing to do is just really make
it all visible to the people who are
dealing with this so if the users who
are doing cloud don't look at their bill
and don't know what's getting spending
there the likelihood that they're gonna
change their behavior to reduce cost is
absolutely no so making it as visible as
possible and as easy for them to
understand what how their behavior is
affecting the costs is huge also I would
also reiterate that educating people on
the different services and how they're
charged is really key
if someone to put an app engine app on
App Engine flexible because that was
their preference at the time and they
don't realize that that app runs 24/7
whereas an app engine standard app only
runs when it's needed I mean that's a
huge difference it can be the difference
between something that you pay every
month for and something that maybe
doesn't cost anything similarly like if
people are you know used to spinning up
sequel databases and they have them
running all the time and they don't know
about bigquery and that they might be
able to store more data in bigquery get
better performance and that lower cost I
think that's huge too so we really need
to educate people on sort of the
features of the platform and where the
cost savings are then I would also
mention about labels we've we've done a
lot with labels we started out just
using labels to sort of do what we do
now with billing accounts to know which
cost object a certain thing would build
to and then the next level of that was
like how does my dev and buyer
cost differently than my prod
environment which labels are very useful
for but in our environment a lot of our
analysis and the cloud runs in kind of a
workflow format where you have many
steps of a workflow occurring to get a
single job done and we are actually able
to put labels on each of the steps of a
workflow so that even though you might
know the cost of that analysis
you also know the cost of each step of
the analysis so the team that's
developing that particular part if their
thing is the most expensive part of the
process they're very incentivized to
improve the performance of their step so
that it reduces cost and the labels that
that be very very visible so everyone
can sort of see it and take action great
this is a great recommendations it
sounds like essentially driving
visibility and accountability is key
sound like there's a little bit of
tooling a little bit of pricing
optimization that's available through
committed use discounts which is great
how many of you are using GK in order to
manage your cost anyone all right Dale
take this one so one of the questions
that we got is is if I am using GK how
do i how do I organize my cost in order
to understand and be able to charge back
why namespace those costs to the
internal departments yeah so for a
background here Lukas talks about having
twenty five thousand projects I have one
project that accounts for over seventy
percent of my billing so actually diving
into that project and understanding a
lot more about what's happening in that
project is really important to me and a
significant portion that cost comes in
to kubernetes and so having the billing
aware like kubernetes aware because
things like namespaces are actually a
really relevant thing in terms of
breaking down those costs and then you
know actually monitoring those costs are
important because people may find out I
mean we talked about that they're their
dev environment or their demo
environment is absolutely crushing
something and they forgot that they're
not using that and those are important
to break down especially in environment
where I mean we're a modestly sized
company and we've got well over 200
micro services running at any one time
in our kubernetes cluster and so it all
it takes is for one of those services to
be out of whack and it may be doesn't it
doesn't present itself at the project
level but if you were looking each one
of them you can
actually see that so that's a very
helpful thing that we've been looking at
excellent and I apologize we are running
out of time so some of the other
questions that I've been asked in the
Dory will try to answer offline just
really quickly Dale any closing thoughts
for the audience any closing thoughts I
just thought of one other thing is is
there in terms of a show it has anybody
here use spanner or big table can we we
don't have a ton of people but I mean
interestingly enough I think it's
Spotify that put out a open-source tool
for actually scaling up and down
BigTable and and we actually modified
that to work for spanner and that made a
significant difference so I don't know I
think making cause a cause public in
looking for these kind of things cuz
auto scaling is like one of the things
that really does reduce cost I mean it's
the promise of the cloud right so my
thoughts make your cost visible and and
I guess just look at always working on
it maybe one order slowly tactical thing
that we haven't talked on we didn't
really talk too much about networking
it'd be worthwhile to look at how much
your data is spanning within a zone but
also between zones and across regions
some of that might be unintentional you
might be charging a little bit more than
you expect to there and may not be
getting a benefit so just looking at
where your job you're there's traveling
across the zones and regions could be
worthwhile yeah I I would like to read
at one point of understanding the
importance of cost management solution
in place so if you're not already
thinking about it that I would want to
reiterate and another thing in terms of
we talked about how do you we talked
about tooling in many organizations you
don't have a choice of coming up with
for example data story we looked at at
many customers but many organizations
already have a tooling for cost
management because DCP is not their
first cost component they may have other
closed private cloud Colo all other
things so you may not have a choice in
terms of tooling but make that choice
early on because one example one
experience we had was in one of the
retailers we started off with the
on-prem data storage using elk stag and
tableau nothing wrong with the platform
per se but the system was so so slow in
terms of adapting to our agile
methodology that we had to switch back
to bigquery and then tableau mgcp so
make the tooling decision also very
early on thinking not just from today's
requirements but what you would do in
coming days and lastly I would say
automate for optimization that I forgot
to mention earlier that for cost
reduction we came up with many ideas for
offer of automation you can create
environments like sandbox time box
environments this environment is
provision to the dev team but it will be
automatically recycled in in two weeks
or three weeks so time bound
environments are we for some of the dev
teams which are using lot of lot of cost
what we did for them was all the dev
environments all the projects label
labeled as Dave would be shut down all
the instances will be shut down or the
weekend right or out of the office hours
so you can use automation to really
optimize the cost using labels all right
and look I so ask you to keep it fast
because we're running out of time well I
talk mostly about how to do things at
scale so I'll actually just give a hint
to people who have a very simple billing
setup i'm google bills on the calendar
month so if you set up a budget that
will alert you let's say at 50% and if
you receive the alert from that budget
and it's before the 15th of the month
then that's problematic and if it's
after the 15th of the month you don't
need to worry about it
awesome that's that's good point thank
you Lucas just closing thoughts one of
the questions what can I learn more
about cost management we have a bunch of
sessions that you can attend this in
fact twelve sessions throughout Google
next this year I would recommend you
take that opportunity to check in some
of those other sessions it's gonna teach
you about things like data studio and
how to set budgets for your environment
so please take that opportunity we also
have a bunch of other material on our
website that will point you towards
webinars and other things where you can
learn about cost management tooling
thank you all for your time
[Applause]
[Music]